qu'ils soient munis de pancartes ou
qu'il frappe sur des casseroles c'est
thaïlandais n'ont pas envie de se taire
mercredi il était un peu plus d'un
millier dans la capitale à se faire
entendre
depuis hier
quatre personnes ont été arrêtées par le
tribunal au sujet de l'article 112
c'est à dire la loi thaïlandaise sur le
lèse majesté
hier on a mis a été arrêté ils ont
besoin de nous nous devons nous exprimer
pour les libérer et dénoncer cette
injustice dans notre pays à la tête du
mouvement de jeunesse contestataire
entamé en juillet pour demander
notamment la démission du gouvernement
et une réforme de la monarchie
quatre leaders ont été inculpés mardi
pour sédition un crime passible de sept
ans de prison
abrogée en 2018 la loi de lèse majesté a
été rétablie par le roi rama 10 en
novembre et mesure inédite
la demande de liberté provisoire a été
refusé aux quatre leaders de la
manifestation
la goutte de trop je ne peux pas
accepter ce gouvernement et le fait
qu'il utilise l'article 112 qu'on se
débarrasser des personnes qui
s'expriment et de la liberté
d'expression
c'est injuste la loi n'est pas valable
je compte faire tout ce que je peux pour
me joindre à cette manifestation et
faire de mon mieux je ne sais pas
comment nous pouvons nous exprimer
autrement
selon les ong taille liars for human
rights
58 militants font face à diverses
accusations de lèse majesté et encourent
jusqu'à 15 ans de prison
en alignant les peines une situation qui
inquiète jusqu'aux nations unies nous
sommes profondément troublés par la
hausse signalé du nombre de poursuites
pour lèse majesté depuis fin 2020 et les
peines de prison infligées qui semble
plus sévère en décembre le bureau des
droits de l'homme des nations unies
avait appelé la thaïlande a amendé la
loi soit quoi le monarque thaïlandais ne
semblent pas disposées en janvier la
thaïlandaise anchan prix laërt avait été
condamné à une peine de quarante trois
ans de prison pour avoir posté des
vidéos où elle critiquait le roi ces
publications remonter à 2015